hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my episode of arrow most hardcore
episode ever just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet hands down
favorite reaction in the episode was
when cagey beast walks in on Oliver
torturing that dude and says what is
this he's just completely horrified oh
my god this is disgusting I woke up with
headache I came to find you I'm not
expecting this this is not human so on
that note I will say there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video you don't have
to burn your Bratva tattoo or give up
your identity is the green arrow or
anything like that so let's do top 10
WTF in comic book Easter eggs but there
was so much craziness in so many deep
cuts in Easter eggs from previous
episodes in the series including
surprise cameos so we haven't seen the
rest of the season yet but I'll say
early pig this is gonna be one of my
favorite episodes from season five but
number 10 prometheus is torturing Oliver
and they're flashing back and forth to
him killing his father and he explains
the origin of the name Prometheus the
person who stole power from the gods
people who were unworthy so it's a bit
of an easter egg for the cry for justice
justice lee comic that was a big
Prometheus storyline where he tries to
take down the Justice League one by one
but is also a lot like unworthy Thor in
the Marvel Universe if you don't know
what's going on in that storyline it's
just a story of how gorges the gods and
starts killing them one by one because
he feels like they do nothing for
mankind they create nothing they don't
care about anyone but themselves
they're just pretenders they're just
lying to everyone and that's what
prometheus is saying to Oliver he's
trying to get him to confess to
something but it takes in most of the
episode to come around on what that is
and it's a huge revelation but number
nine in the flashbacks we find out that
Khobar is planning to wash over like a
biblical flood everything of Oliver's is
going to end everything he touches is
going to wither and die and it sort of
serves as like a prophecy for what's
happening in the future it's the same
thing that Prometheus has been feeding
him all season everything you touch you
infect all your friends this is all
based on a lie
so one of my favorite moments in the
episode number eight is when malcolm
merlyn shows up in coe VARs office
arranging for a Kovar to steal the sarin
gas so now we know that Malcolm Merlyn
was dealing with kovar but they don't
make any references to the undertaking
or anything that Merlyn might be
planning they just say that his
compensation is going to be some form of
information so we'll find out more about
that probably later this season and
it'll have something to do with the
undertaking in the Earthshaker device
because he got that from markovia and
based on some of the twists in the
episode I mean we're in Russia right now
but it sounds like Kovar is gonna go to
ground somewhere else so I think what
they're trying to imply is that Merlyn
got the Earthshaker device from Kovar
but that's something separate from what
happened in this episode they're sort of
teeing that up we might get that reveal
later this season so either way number
seven Kovar explains two cagey beasts
what the revolution he has planned is
he's gonna overthrow the government but
it does sound like he has good
intentions like he feels like the Soviet
Union collapsed and then the people who
were in power just hoarded more power
and it didn't help anyone so he wants to
get rid of them and install a new
government it's really the tactics that
you would argue over like he plans to
murder them all so it's like okay we
want a new government there are probably
less stabby ways to go about that but
you see what they're doing here Kovar is
doing the same thing that Oliver was
doing during season one with the list
there were all those people on the list
in season one that we're failing
Starling city so Oliver took them down
Kovar feels like there are all these
people in this room here that are
failing Russia so he wants to take them
down too but there's just another way
that they're showing you that Oliver is
every bit the monster that Kovar is in
the past so Oliver refuses to leave
they're gonna take him down
number six Prometheus starts throwing
Oliver skills in his face and they start
arguing morality so you have this crazy
town banana pants argument where
Prometheus isn't trying to argue that
he's good but he's just trying to get
Oliver to come around on the idea that
he is that monster that he's trying to
dress up in the hood one of the first
big Easter eggs is they eat polls count
Vertigo's picture up he's like you know
who this was this was the count you
killed him and he was referring to
season 2 when he was getting ready to
kill felicity so I think when he
actually killed him that was
after he had dedicated himself to not
killing people but I think the question
was is that he had threatened her life
so he sort of hit pause on the no
killing button just because she was in
so much danger and if you're doing a
body count he still did kill people each
season after that but usually it was
less and less but he was still stabby
but he dropped way less bodies and I
think that damian darhk-- was one of the
only people he killed in present day
during season four but then number five
then it gets real serious
Prometheus pulls out a picture of all of
her son he also has something from
Felicity's apartment he's just
threatening all of his friends but the
son thing is big because Oliver's like I
don't even know where he is how are you
gonna find him and of course if
Prometheus knows all about shado in the
people on the island that Oliver hasn't
told anyone about besides Deathstroke
and maybe a couple of team arrow people
and he is good at finding information
and will track his son down in short
order so it's not a question of if it's
a question of when and I love how they
just opposed this with Oliver torturing
Cove arts man in the flashbacks - and of
course KGB's walks down after they're
done is like oh my god what did you do
here and he says oh he gave up the
information relatively quickly the rest
of this is me just practicing and I
think he dropped an Amanda Waller Easter
Egg when he was talking about the friend
that taught him out ask in a
large-animal really quickly she was the
one that taught him out of torture
people during the season three
flashbacks when they were in Hong Kong
so number four things get even more
interesting welcome back Artemis goodbye
Artemis so I love how they try to get
them to kill each other Oliver's like
I'm not gonna kill her he walks in sure
enough snaps her neck puts her on the
ground
I love the reveal later in the episode -
but the way she's sold being broken I
can't take it anymore Oliver it sounds
like she had been there ever since the
mid-season finale when she disappeared
either way it all winds up being an act
so I wonder how they're gonna bring her
back around at the end of the season
because she'll be so damaged after this
even though she still kind of sounds
like she believes that Oliver needs to
suffer for what he's done you're a lie
you're lying to yourself you're not
making the city better you know that
Oliver's the Green Arrow good will
triumph eventually meaning there's going
to be a reckoning for the villains just
like Oliver had a reckoning in this
episode with himself but where does that
leave
the Evelyn character she's gonna be even
more damaged than Thea's character but I
do like her Ark more than I like Thea's
Ark and previous seasons with the
bloodlust I feel like even just in this
episode it was just a more compelling
performance so I really like what the
actress was doing the way she sold being
broken by Prometheus like you look at
her and you really believe it like I
totally bought that until the twist when
she was like ah see see he's totally a
monster he admitted to it but number two
Oliver vs Khobar in the flashbacks just
a great fight sequence of course Dolph
Lundgren is gonna bring the pain but
because this is only episode 17 of 23
and they it's just such a big character
there's no way they're gonna kill him
off this quickly so that's why Oliver
won I think it was just as a result of
that so he's gonna come back bigger and
badder than ever I love the way his eyes
open - it's almost like a horror movie
or something that you would see
Deathstroke - because of the mirakuru
like he would go down hard and then just
come back like a zombie just super crazy
so I loved the Merlyn twist that he's
still in league with him like I said I
think this is all leading up to Merlyn
getting the Earthshaker device for the
season 1 undertaking because that was
all getting started whenever Oliver
showed up in Starling so I almost forgot
I haven't mentioned it yet they did this
funny thing where they danced around
revealing who Malcolm Merlyn was when
Oliver found out an American was dealing
with Kovar like KGB she said Oh some
American businessman was helping him out
and then again at the end of the episode
when Merlyn says who did this to him and
the man says that's between him and
Kovar so the reason they did that you
probably picked up on this it's because
in season 1 of arrow Oliver didn't know
that Merlyn was evil and Merlin didn't
know that Oliver was the hood right away
so it's just a way to protect the
continuity of the show so Merlyn can't
find out about Oliver in the flashbacks
Oliver can't find out about Merlyn but
number 1 the big reveal Oliver confesses
that he enjoys killing he is that
monster in all the dialogue the cagey
beast had in the flashbacks was totally
on point like he basically tells Oliver
you're lying to yourself you can put the
hood on but it's only gonna make the
monster stronger you're that same person
when we found each other for the first
time in I BOS prison you're the killer
not the person wearing the hood and then
obviously in present day they kind of
juxtapose him getting the proper tattoo
with
Prometheus sort of burning it off with
the blowtorch that was hardcore
that is so funny watching this right
after watching that flash musical
episode it's like two ends of the
spectrum night in day Oliver getting
tortured in the basement while Barry and
Cara are just dancing the night away in
their dreams and I almost forgot the
title of the episode Kapoor Sean that's
Russian for hood I don't speak Russian
but that's the way they refer to it so
that was the way they were using the
title of the episode talking about the
monster that is Oliver Queen in the
flashbacks and in present day so I love
the idea that team arrow is disbanding
there's no way they're gonna stay
disbanded for the rest of the season but
what is gonna happen to bring them back
together I wonder so let me know in the
comments what did you think about the
episode is this going to be one of your
favorite episodes of the season so far
and can you not wait to see the Bratva
roll up in Star City next week and just
bring the pain it seems like it's gonna
be all-out war Star City will not be
safe until Chase is in the ground and
there is no price I will not pay to see
that happen I need you to kill Adrian
chase
you and the team will be fine we did
stay away from Jason
so what's gonna happen next this is a
whole bunch of bombs just dropped there
was a Justice League teaser trailer I
just posted I'll post a longer breakdown
of what's going on with that with
Aquaman there are a bunch of you that
are requesting a Legion video and
Michael Shannon Zod himself from Man of
Steel and Batman vs Superman is
announced as the lead pick for cable in
Deadpool 2 so let me know in the
comments which video you want me to post
next that's really the only way you guys
have to let me know which one you want
next I have a pretty good idea which
videos you guys want based on comments
but if there's a bunch of stuff
happening I try to prioritize so I'll
say congratulations to the new flash
ring giveaway winner Jesus Zaius
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video announce the
winner the next time I post a DC video
while you wait for that click here to
rewatch that Justice League trailer and
click here for a new flash thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video